we are launching a new series this
morning called what's working
our goal is to highlight the innovations
that are paying off
in america in areas from education to
infrastructure
and much more so we're going to start
this morning with a new state-of-the-art
bridge in new york
built on time and on budget it's part of
the governor mario
m cuomo bridge and it opens tonight it
replaces the aging
tappan zee bridge over the hudson river
construction took four years and cost
nearly 4 billion dollars
we climbed to the top of the new bridge
with current new york governor andrew
cuomo to find out what it took to get
construction underway
it's one of the largest construction
projects in the country
i think we're crossing over here and a
rare success story
in the saga of american infrastructure
what's it like when you get to see it
this up close it's almost unbelievable
you know we've been planning it talking
about it
but to now actually see the reality of
it and to see it in comparison to the
old bridge is really striking a 3.1 mile
cable stay bridge named the governor
mario m
cuomo bridge by his son current new york
governor
andrew cuomo the cost 3.9 billion
dollars
this was decades decades in the making
hundreds of meetings fights about it
not an easy process no they talked about
changing the bridge for literally
20 years everybody says the bridge is
dangerous
everybody says it has to be replaced but
nothing happens
you think there's political risk in
actually building this oh sure there is
sure there is it's one of the reasons
the politicians
stay away from it we have a lot of big
infrastructure projects that we've tried
in the past they haven't worked out and
they can be a career
ender right so did that go through your
mind oh only about seven times a week
the most spectacular project on the
thruway is the three mile bridge
the existing bridge the tappan zee was
long ago
deemed functionally obsolete it's 12
years past its expiration date the cuomo
bridge is the result of a public-private
partnership
designed and built by a private company
and overseen
by project director jamie barbus how
long can a bridge like this last
the requirement for this bridge is 100
years of service life
the structure in hull should last 100
years it's built to last
yes it is longer than us i think
building it has taken seven thousand
workers more than nine million
hours 220 million pounds of american
steel
and enough concrete to stretch from here
to key west
much of it was made on land floated down
the hudson river
and maneuvered into place by a super
crane dubbed
i lift new york could you have built
this bridge without that crane
no not in the component so if you look
behind me and you see these beams are
put together
and put on a barge and lifted completely
in place to span from peer-to-peer
the super crane was shipped to new york
from california it paid a
70 thousand dollar toll to pass through
the panama canal
wow this is pretty spectacular but it
was worth it
it is about perspective isn't it and
this gives you perspective
i'm taking in what is just an incredible
view to be up here without
um without losing my lunch because if i
look down one more time
oh come on there aren't even walls here
on the side they're just pieces of rope
the first span of the bridge is opening
on time and on budget
once complete the bridge is expected to
carry more than 140
000 vehicles every day the tolls on this
bridge are only like five dollars
can you promise the people of new york
that you won't raise the toll prices
we've promised that the tolls won't be
raised through
2020 and then we're gonna have to see
where the finances for the state are in
2020.
so you're not worried when people are
cursing the traffic on this bridge that
they'll be like it's the cuomo bridge
uh i don't think they'll curse the
traffic on this bridge
the traffic will be less on this bridge
than the old bridge
it will take another year to dismantle
the old bridge and complete the cuomo
which the governor hopes will serve as a
symbol for new york ambition
and a model for big building in america
if the tappan zee bridge was the poster
child
for crumbling infrastructure in america
the cuomo bridge will be the poster
child for what
for the optimism and the capacity and
the
competence that you doubt what made
america is what we built
the railroads the tunnels the bridges
the skyscrapers
we can't lose that if we lose that we
lose who we
are all right now getting us that super
crane that we showed you
that helped build the new bridge what's
also going to take down the old bridge
because they have to take it down piece
by piece for environmental concerns
they're going to recycle them and that
super crane can lift
12 statues of liberty at once wow they
call it the lebron james great that's
very
very well named beautiful piece nora
and i can't imagine what it must be like
for the governor to have the bridge
named after his dad well as we talk
about infrastructure one of these few
bipartisan things that president trump
could potentially do let's rebuild
america that that thought that people
could
could you do it this is an example of
actually this public-private partnership
and it worked they did it in four years
it's a success story you look at the
golden gate and wonder could we do that
today
yeah this is sort of proof that it's
doable right so we want to highlight
good stories as well here certainly do i
like that what's working